Certains pensent qu'il existe une recette pour une conférence TED :
« Faire un discours sur le rond rouge »,
« Raconter un souvenir d'enfance »,
« Dévoiler un secret intime »,
« Lancer un appel à l'action inspiré ».
Non.
Ce n'est pas une manière d'envisager une conférence TED.
En fait, si vous utilisez trop ces artifices,
vous allez faire vraiment cliché ou manipulateur des émotions.
Mais toutes les conférences TED ont quelque chose en commun
et je voudrais le partager avec vous.
Parce que ces 12 dernières années, j'étais aux premières loges,
à écouter des centaines de conférenciers TED surprenants, comme ceux-là.
Je les ai aidés à préparer leur discours pour le grand soir
et c'est d'eux que j'ai appris
les secrets pour faire un super discours.
Et même si tous ces orateurs et leurs sujets semblaient
vraiment différents,
ils avaient tous un élément clé en commun.
Et c'est ceci :
votre tâche numéro un en tant qu'orateur
est d'arriver à faire entrer dans l'esprit des auditeurs
un cadeau extraordinaire, beau et étrange qu'on appelle une idée.
Laissez-moi vous expliquer.
Voici Haley.
Elle va bientôt faire sa conférence
et franchement, elle est terrifiée.
(Vidéo ) Présentateur : Haley Van Dyck !
(Applaudissements)
Pendant 18 minutes,
1 200 personnes, des inconnus pour la plupart,
commencent à sentir leur esprit en phase avec celui de Haley
et avec ceux des autres.
Tout le monde génère littéralement les mêmes ondes cérébrales.
Et je ne veux pas juste dire qu'ils ressentent la même chose.
Quelque chose de plus est en train de se produire.
Regardons dans l'esprit de Haley pendant un instant.
Il y a des milliards de neurones interconnectés tout enchevêtrés.
Mais regardez là, juste là,
quelques millions d'entre eux sont liés entre eux
pour représenter une seule idée.
Et de façon incroyable, le même schéma prend forme en même temps
dans l'esprit de tous les auditeurs.
C'est vrai : en quelques minutes seulement
un schéma qui mobilise des millions de neurones
est téléporté dans 1 200 esprits,
par le simple fait d'écouter une voix et de regarder un visage.
Mais attendez : qu'est-ce qu'une idée en fait ?
Eh bien, vous pouvez penser que c'est un type d'information
qui vous aide à comprendre et à évoluer dans le monde.
Les idées ont toutes sortes de formes et de tailles,
depuis les complexes et analytiques
aux simples et esthétiques.
Voici quelques exemples partagés sur la scène de TED.
Sir Ken Robinson - La créativité est la clé du futur de nos enfants.
(Vidéo) Sir Ken Robinson : J'estime que la créativité de nos jours
est aussi importante que l'alphabétisation,
et nous devrions lui accorder la même importance.
Chris Anderson : Elora Hardy à propos des constructions en bambou.
(Vidéo ) Elora Hardy : Il pousse tout autour de nous.
Il est fort, il est élégant, ils résiste aux séismes.
CA : Chimamanda Adichie - les gens n'ont pas qu'une identité.
(Vidéo) Chimamanda Adichie: L'histoire crée des stéréotypes
et le problème avec les stéréotypes n'est pas qu'ils sont faux
mais qu'ils sont incomplets.
CA : Votre esprit regorge d'idées
et pas de manière aléatoire.
Elles sont vraiment liées entre elles.
Collectivement, elles forment une structure complexe incroyable
qui est votre vision du monde.
Voilà comment fonctionne votre cerveau.
C'est ainsi que vous comprenez le monde.
Il se compose de millions d'idées différentes.
Si par exemple un élément de votre vision du monde
est l'idée que les chatons sont adorables,
alors quand vous verrez cela,
vous réagirez comme ça.
Mais si un autre élément de votre vision du monde
est l'idée que les léopards sont dangereux,
alors quand vous voyez cela,
vous réagissez un peu différemment.
On comprend mieux alors
pourquoi les idées qui composent votre vision du monde sont cruciales.
Elles doivent être un guide aussi fiable que possible
dans le vrai monde, effrayant mais magnifique.
Or des individus différents peuvent avoir des visions radicalement différentes.
Par exemple,
comment votre pensée réagit-elle quand vous voyez cette image ?
(Vidéo) Dalia Mogahed : Que pensez-vous quand vous me regardez ?
« Une femme de foi ? Une experte ? Peut-être même un sœur ? »
ou « Oppressée, endoctrinée,
terroriste ? »
CA : Quelle que soit votre réponse,
des millions d'autres personnes réagiront différemment.
Voilà pourquoi les idées sont importantes.
Si on les partage correctement,
elles sont capables de changer pour toujours
la vision du monde de certaines personnes
et d'orienter leurs actions maintenant mais aussi dans le futur.
Les idées sont la force la plus puissante qui façonne la culture humaine.
Donc si vous acceptez
que le principal défi d'un orateur est de construire une idée
dans l'esprit de l'auditoire,
voici 4 grandes lignes à suivre pour remplir votre mission :
Un : limitez votre discours à une seule grande idée.
Les idées sont complexes :
il faut fouiller votre esprit et vous concentrer
sur l'idée qui vous passionne le plus
et vous donner une chance de l'expliquer clairement.
Il faut donner le contexte, des exemples, rendre cela vivant.
Alors choisissez une idée
et faites que ce soit le fil rouge de tout votre discours,
pour que tout ce que vous direz s'y rattache tout le temps.
Deux : donnez aux auditeurs une bonne raison de vous écouter.
Avant de commencer à faire entrer des choses dans l'esprit des auditeurs,
ils doivent vous inviter à entrer.
Et quel est le meilleur moyen pour cela ?
La curiosité.
Attisez la curiosité des auditeurs.
Posez des questions intrigantes, provocantes
pour identifier pourquoi quelque chose n'a pas de sens et qu'on doit l'expliquer.
Si vous pouvez révéler une faille dans la vision du monde d'une personne,
elle ressentira le besoin de combler ce manque de connaissance.
Et une fois ce désir éveillé,
ce sera beaucoup plus facile de commencer à développer votre idée.
Trois : développez votre idée, par petits morceaux,
hors des concepts que votre auditoire connaît déjà.
Utilisez le pouvoir du langage
pour tisser ensemble des concepts existants
dans l'esprit des auditeurs
mais pas votre langage, leur langage.
Commencez où ils en sont.
Les conférenciers oublient souvent
que la plupart des termes et concepts qu'ils utilisent
ne sont vraiment pas familiers pour leurs auditeurs.
Les métaphores peuvent alors jouer un rôle crucial
pour imbriquer les différents morceaux,
car elles révèlent la forme définitive de l'idée,
basée sur le fait que les auditeurs comprennent déjà.
Par exemple, quand Jennifer Kahn
veut expliquer ce qu'est l'incroyable nouvelle biotechnologie appelée CRISPR,
elle dit : « C'est comme si, pour la première fois
il existait un traitement de texte pour éditer d'ADN.
Le CRISPR nous permet de copier-coller les données génétiques très facilement. »
Une explication vivante comme cela offre un moment de grande satisfaction
alors que cela se met en place dans nos esprits.
Il est donc important de tester votre discours sur des amis de confiance
et trouver les moments où cela leur paraît confus.
Quatre, le dernier point :
trouvez une idée qui vaille la peine d'être partagée.
Ce que je veux dire c'est posez-vous la question :
« À qui va profiter cette idée ? »
Et vous devez être honnête quant à la réponse.
Si l'idée ne profite qu'à vous ou à votre organisation,
alors, désolé, mais elle ne vaut probablement pas la peine d'être partagée.
L'auditoire verra clair dans votre jeu.
Mais si vous croyez que votre idée a la possibilité
d'illuminer la journée de quelqu'un d'autre,
de changer en mieux les perspectives d'une personne
ou de motiver quelqu'un à faire quelque chose différemment,
alors vous avez l'élément central pour un grand discours efficace,
de ceux qui peuvent être un cadeau pour eux et pour chacun d'entre nous.